大家好 歡迎收聽信息的凡來賬河 我是老漢。
我是雪梨
我們這一期的主題是夏天。
我不知道是不是我的錯覺。
我就感覺怎麼現在一年要比一年的溫度高了。
那不是錯覺 那就是真實的感覺。
就是在我的記憶裡。
小時候很難聽到35度以上的天氣。
到了每年最熱最熱的時候。
可能也就是31、23度就了不定了。
然後像現在尤其是今年。
就感覺40度天氣好正常。
而且不僅是在國內。
其實日本我會感覺近幾年每年夏天的溫度。
其實也是在逐漸升高的。
對 所以它特意還給30度以上的天氣。
定了一個專業的名字叫酷暑日。
而且大家可能也看新聞了。
其實不僅是國內其實在日本。
最近因為高溫而導致的新聞事件。
還是相比於往年多少多呢？
尤其是日本這邊最近半個月吧？
我看新聞說日本全國大概有個1萬多人。
都因為中暑而被救護車拉到了醫院。
這個數字還是挺令我覺得震撼的。
對 因為今年日本其實熱的算是比較晚的了。
聽咱們之前《梅雨季》那期節目的朋友們。
可能知道今年日本梅雨季的時間。
會拉得比較長一些。
你想到了7月初的時候。
其實我們這邊還是比較涼爽的。
對 那個時候完全不需要開空調。
而且晚上睡覺的時候都是得蓋被子的。
嗯 但是不僅是梅雨季今年比較反常。
而且夏天來的也是比較反常的。
就是往年的氣氛其實是逐步升高。
但是今年不是
今年是7月初那時23、24度。
然後到了中旬梅雨季只要一過。
就從23、24度變成了35、26度了。
就感覺中間那些氣溫被吃掉了。
對 雖然說溫度可能相對於國內來說沒有這麼高。
但是它的跳躍性或者快躍性。
其實還挺令人驚訝。
或者挺令人促步及防的。
對 所以在7月的時候。
7月初還是有點涼液。
但是等到7月中旬就熱的不行了。
而且我發現日本的這個熱。
跟天津北京的熱可能還不太一樣。
就是天津的熱是那種濕熱。
就像蒸籠一樣
935天桑拿天嗎。
對 但是日本的這種熱是甘熱。
而且除了這個熱的感覺不一樣以外。
其實我剛來日本的時候。
我會覺得日本的夏天很短。
就是在天津是沒有春秋的。
它只有冬夏
在北方我覺得都這樣。
所以就感覺這個夏天格外的場。
進了五一就開始到夏天了。
一直要熱到10月份。
對
五一跟十一其實是評判。
夏天和冬天的兩個標準。
然後可能還有一個秋老虎。
然後再熱幾天
對
但是日本不是
日本因為它是一個島國。
所以它的四季比較分明。
其實真正到了夏天的時候也就是7月初。
當然這正常來說
今年比較不正常
所以它到了7月中旬。
然後一直到8月底9月初的時候。
其實酷暑的這段日子就算是過去了。
當然一直到9月份 10月份還是會熱一支。
但是這個熱的話
晚上就沒有這麼難熬了。
對
就是還比較舒適的一個程度。
而且我覺得日本雖然是四季分明。
但是它的四季是要比國內往後推了一個月的。
除了這以外
其實日本和國內過夏天的方式。
其實也有很大的區別。
在國內可能到了夏天以後。
西瓜綠豆湯冰菇算是一種標配。
而且在國內是可以實現西瓜自由的。
就是我對於夏天唯一的期待。
可能就是可以放肆的吃西瓜。
所以你現在的東京過夏天也有這種期待嗎。
不敢
就在日本你是不可能去期待西瓜自由的。
也有可能是咱們兩個太窮了。
不是
就是大家都這樣
太貴了
在國內一個西瓜一斤一塊錢五毛錢。
現在在日本一個西瓜100多人民幣。
所以這麼多年過來了以後。
其實西瓜對於我來說已經變成了一個長心。
就是每到了夏天嘗一嘗。
嘗一嘗
而且冰菇也是
在我小的時候
或者我在國內生活的記憶裡。
其實到了夏天賣冰菇。
還真正多起來
但是日本好像一年四季都在吃冰淇淋。
就永遠有這個東西。
對 所以我覺得冬天吃冰淇淋。
其實也是一件很正常的事。
冬天有冬天的限定。
夏天有夏天的限定。
巧克力限定
就感覺冰棍的一個東西。
在日本已經失去了季節屬性。
日本雖然說沒有這些東西。
但是它也有一些比較特色的過夏天的方式。
所以今天這期節目我們就來聊一聊。
日本人他們是怎麼過夏天的。
以及日本人過夏天的這種方式。
對我和雪梨這兩個外國人的生活。
有什麼樣的影響
首先我覺得在國內和在日本過夏天。
最大的區別就是
我在日本可以實現空調自由。
怎麼你以前沒有空調自由嗎。
誰有空調自由
你有空調自由嗎
誰現在來聽我們你們說。
你們在家裡頭
哪個沒有被長輩說過。
別開空調 吹感冒了。
你晚上關上
你睡覺的時候把空調關上。
哎呀 開什麼空調。
開電池就夠了
這還沒有到這麼熱的時候。
你沒有被這樣說過嗎。
我沒有
我在國內的時候每年都被說。
哦 原來是這樣
我自己其實是一個特別怕熱的人。
以至於我在家裡面。
我一直想把空調開到18度最大風。
然後這個時候
我爸就會過來默默的把這個門關上。
就是你冷冷你這個屋就行了。
你不要冷我
他是覺得不熱是吧？
不是 他也熱
他在外面吹著電扇擦著汗。
但是他就非得把你那屋的門關上。
對 因為他會覺得。
空調這個東西吹多了容易得病。
所以他不想得病就把你那門關上。
讓你自己得病
你拿我老了的話說。
就是空調的涼風
是順著皮膚往骨頭糞你鑽。
就是
你這也得不讓他受傷。
他會覺得不舒服
我也不知道從哪聽的。
他們說這個空調吹多了會得空調病。
空調病所謂的就是說。
其實吹多了關鍵難受。
或者說肩膀哪兒的疼。
說實話
我到現在其實對於空調病的一個。
具體的定義是什麼。
我都不知道
說實話嗎
你也不知道
不是
我以前是沒有這種體驗的。
但是隨著最近年齡越來越大。
我不知道是不是因為自己老了。
就是我現在吹空調。
如果吹久了之後
我會感覺肩膀和膝蓋是涼的。
你感覺那個涼風也順著你股頭糞往裡鑽。
他現在還沒有順著股頭糞往裡鑽。
但是膝蓋骨頭他是涼的。
所以我就覺得涼的好像有點不舒服。
那說明你老了
對
就有時候在家
得穿長褲才行
人老先老腿嗎
是
所以得保護好膝蓋嗎。
而且即使是這樣
到了我睡覺的時候。
他們只要發現我對吳空調是開著的。
他們一定會把門開一開進來。
把空調關上
跟我說
睡覺就把空調關上。
那一晚上睡覺的時候會被熱醒嗎。
對 無一例外的
只要再把空調關上。
我們每一天都會被熱醒。
也是辛苦你了
我以前上學的時候有這樣的體驗。
就是我記得上高中的時候。
那個時候我們那空調。
也是只給開到晚上11點。
西燈睡覺了就給關上了。
你們宿舍還有空調呢？
有
我長這麼大
我在國內上的這麼多年學。
我從來沒有待過帶空調的教室。
也從來沒有住過帶空調的宿舍。
你小初高大學全這樣嗎。
對
天哪
那咱們倆簡直有帶勾了。
小學初中高中是在天井上的。
那是走讀
然後在教室裡面也沒有空調。
只有老師的辦公室有空調。
所以到了夏天
我們只能下課以後往老的辦公室裡面鑽。
天哪
然後到了大學
我大學在東北上
對吧？
要什麼空調
但是也很熱的夏天。
真的很熱的
尤其到了中午的時候。
長春也挺熱的說實話。
然後也沒有空調
那你那時候不管是在家裡邊。
還是在學校都是一個非常熱的狀態。
這就非常難
但是對於我來說的話。
小時候唯一就是有被熱醒的體驗。
就是在學校裡邊空調11點。
都被那個蘇管阿姨給關上之後。
早上起來的這一段記憶。
所以有時候早上起來。
一般都得在那個洗腦間給身上先鋪點涼水。
我覺得他們就是沒股硬吃。
你知道嗎
就是有空調
當然不給你用
然後這個情況一直持續到我來的日本以後。
就到了日本以後
才知道什麼叫做空調自由。
雖然你失去了西瓜自由。
但是獲得了空調自由。
對
我當時上學的時候。
住的那個房間比較小。
所以我的那個空調。
我就一直開著
最開始的時候我還是開著這個智能。
到後來我也不知道從哪學的。
我學會了這個廚師功能。
我發現廚師功能真的很好用。
雖然我對於你說
你來日本之後才學會廚師。
就這件事覺得有點意外。
但是這麼一想
確實你以前沒有空調自由。
所以你不知道廚師也很正常。
對啊？
我甚至在以前都不知道廚師這個功能是幹嘛的。
為什麼要廚師
廚師幹什麼的
廚什麼事
就是空氣裡的事
可能我們家對於這種新鮮事物接受的。
不是特別快
天津其實是一個很潮濕的城市。
就是我們家的廚房。
能潮到往下滴水順著槍。
那你們家跟南方那混蛋貼也沒有區別。
其實很像對不對
但即使是這樣
我長這麼大
從來沒有從我的長輩們嘴裡邊聽過。
我們去買個廚師機。
我們要廚師也沒有。
他們都怪這個天兒真潮。
這個房子太潮了
他們就會怪
對他們沒有想過如何去解決屋子裡面潮濕的這個問題。
所以學會了這個廚師以後。
我在家裡面就是一直開著廚師。
所以工作了到東京來了以後。
雖然說房子變大了。
但是我一直保持著這個習慣。
就是家裡面一直開著廚師。
你說到這個
其實老范這房子
他以前這個二樓
他都是沒有空調的。
對
這個房子雖然是兩層的。
但是他只給配了一個空調。
就是一樓的客廳有一個空調。
所以我跟雪梨在一塊之前。
我也沒想著自己再買一個空調。
一至於每到了夏天。
就現在這個月份的時候。
我都是把辦公桌顯示器。
所有的設備搬到樓下搬到客廳裡。
然後他睡沙發
對
然後放了防暴水
他睡沙發
二樓除了拿衣服以外。
我是幾乎不上來的。
因為我感覺那個樓梯那好像就有個結界一樣。
二樓如果沒有空調。
就你上來的時候
有種怎麼說的逆水的感覺。
我甚至都感覺
特別的悶
還有可能就是因為這個房子是木造的。
它的保溫隔熱
其實做的不是特別好。
對
但是我剛來日本的時候住的大板的小房子。
它就是鋼筋混凝土的。
所以相對木造的來說。
它保溫效果是比較好的。
我那個房子不開空調行。
也就是個28度到頭了。
你不會覺得特別熱。
但是你像我們家那個木造的。
我們基本上晚上下班回來。
其實已經8點多了。
我們到了二樓
二樓的溫度依然有32度。
對
所以就能想像最開始。
老翻在二樓沒有空調的時候。
這是住的是什麼樣的一個房子。
所以我不住二樓嗎。
我覺得你整個體驗也比較差。
放著一個房子
但是其實二樓是用不上的。
所以就是一直到我後來住進來之後。
這個二樓才買了一個空調。
但是這個空調它是裝在臥室的。
就是我們二樓是有兩個房間。
臥室跟書房它是對著的。
其實當時買的時候我們還糾結過。
這空調到底是安在書房呢？
還是安在臥室呢？
那有聽眾朋友們可能會說了。
你不能一屋裝一個嗎。
可以
但是我們窮
當時的一算
你只能支撐買一台空調。
你說如果買兩個小的。
就是那種小匹的
還不如買一個大一點的。
可以兩個屋子都能用上的。
對
我當時買大的
一個是考慮說
我們只有一台的預算。
那買一個大的
可能可以把兩個屋都吹涼。
第二一個又考慮到以後。
可能會搬家
這個空調是肯定會帶走的。
對不對
那搬家到了一個大房子裡面。
有可能這個小空調就比較積累。
索性呢？
現在就買一個大的就可以一直用了。
我是這麼想的
但是買回來發現
雖然說這個空調裝到了臥室裡邊。
但是這個風
它是沒有辦法主動的從臥室吹出去的。
對
這個很奇怪
這個涼氣為什麼出不來呢？
就是兩個門其實挨得挺近的。
但是即使開著門
這個門口好像依然有一個結機。
一樣的東西存在
就是這個涼氣緊陷於這個屋裡面。
就好像一直在那個臥室裡邊自己循環。
就完全沒有往外送。
對
就比如說現在
這個時間是中午的12點。
我們是在書房路的節目。
臥室是開著空調的。
我們現在書房的這個溫度就有28度。
但是臥室只有20度。
對
所以這個時候如果臥室不開一個最大縫。
或者是最低溫度的話。
這個書房其實是待不了的。
對
那如果說臥室開著最大縫。
確實書房室會變得比較涼爽。
但是臥室就冷了
你在臥室待著就得蓋杯了。
雖然說也挺舒服的。
但是你待久了會覺得有點不適。
對
有點過於冷了
所以我們後來又在網上買了一個。
那種專門送風的大蘇澇袋。
我們還是專門花錢買了那個。
但是現在想一想的話。
其實可以自己拿幾個大的垃圾袋。
自己接一個
對
那東西咱只買了一年。
後來就沒買過了
是因為那個東西它會滴水。
冷凝水
經常會弄的地下
床上都是冷凝水
所以你到後來也就不裝這個東西。
直接就用電扇了
對
所以我們現在就是在兩個屋中間立一個電扇。
然後讓風扇把裡邊的涼風往這邊吹。
嗯
然後我們還有好幾個小電扇。
分散在這個房間的不同的角落。
盡量的讓這個房間的空氣循環起來。
你直接去具體買一個那種。
比較好的空氣循環扇就得了嗎。
太貴了這東西
日本的一個空氣循環扇。
可能我記得好像要156的樣子。
你說日圓嗎
對啊？
我說它是便宜的呢？
156好像也沒有很貴啊？
你聽著可能不貴
但是你知道咱們家電扇多少錢嗎。
電扇多少錢
咱們家所有的電扇加一塊還沒有1萬塊錢。
哦是嗎
哦這樣啊？
就這個電扇它這個功能比較簡單。
所以價格也是很便宜是嗎。
對
所以現在呢？
我們家到了夏天
就是上下兩個空調。
一直開著這個廚師。
但我以前自己住的時候。
我好像從來沒開過廚師。
我以前一直開的是智冷。
然後26、7度
但是你不覺得這種空調的這個恆溫做的很差嗎。
就是說把溫度定到了26度。
其實是一個比較舒適的溫度了。
對不對
但是呢？
你依然會覺得熱
你沒有這種感覺嗎。
好像沒有
有可能是咱們倆對於溫度的這個接受程度是不一樣的。
我會覺得26、7度開完之後。
我是比較舒服的
但是也有一種情況。
就是它26度開始延長了。
它這個吹出來的風突然就不冷了。
就變成智熱了
對
這就是我為什麼說它這個恆溫做的很差。
所以有時候一直開廚師。
我會覺得它要比這個智冷26度還要冷一點。
我在以前不知道這個廚師的時候。
其實是一直開的關關的開的。
就開到最低溫最大風。
然後吹冷了以後再關上。
然後一會再開
就是這樣特別費一點。
完
我也是最近才學到的。
你也是最近才學到。
是嗎
一直開著空調相對來說是省電的。
對
但我為什麼以前我自己住的時候一直要開26、7度呢？
是因為我在北京在國內跟我爸媽一塊住的時候。
就是被我爸開那空調凍死了你知道嗎。
就我跟你以前小時候體驗是完全相反的。
你沒有空調自由
同樣的我也沒有空調自由。
我沒有空調自由
是因為我覺得很熱。
你沒有空調自由是你覺得很冷。
對
是因為我爸只要在家。
他就把空調常年打到大風18度。
當然這個風量可能有時候會變。
但是這個溫度是肯定不會變的。
所以我跟我媽待在家的時候經常就凍掉死。
也是得穿長袖長褲才行。
所以我也是到了日本之後才實現了溫度自由。
我一直覺得你爸不是屬於那種典型的60後的父母。
他有點像80後
雖然說你爸和我爸大家都是60後。
他們的年紀相仿
但是他們倆在生活上你就感覺是兩個時代的人。
我爸是那種跟著老一輩非常傳統的那種思想。
但是你爸就有點像80後。
就是他的思想和生活方式比較的潮。
滴水是吧？
對
看見你爸那狀態我就能想像到。
等他老了以後
他一定是一個特別時髦的一個帥老頭。
特別潮的老頭
全身全身冷凝水
而且你說到這個空調。
我覺得中國和日本關於這個清潔其實也不一樣。
就是我來日本以後。
我覺得有一次我想找人去清潔一下空調。
因為爸媽以前在國內。
他每年都會找人去清理一下。
尤其是在換季要開空調之前。
所以有時候就會在網上約一個。
然後一般的話一台空調就是個幾十塊錢。
但是我在日本在網上查了一下價格之後我就死心了。
一般清理一台空調價格是一萬多日圓一台。
一萬多日圓按照內置人呼籲來說的話。
可能得大幾百塊錢。
對
所以我就打消了這個念頭。
就開始只清潔這個濾網。
或者說買一些清潔的噴劑。
就是盡量的保持一個健康。
而且定期的清理空調其實是可以提高智冷效率和省電。
其實還是有必要的。
而且你沒發現吧？
其實在日本沒有見過那種歷史空調或者貴史空調。
就是歷在地上的那種。
對
就是咱們國內歷在客廳裡的那種空調。
你在日本能見到的空調全是掛在牆上的。
甭管大的小的
其實我有點好奇
為什麼日本不賣這種貴市的空調。
它是不是沒有這種場景。
也有
你像是日本的那種大客廳的話。
其實按一個貴市空調。
我覺得智冷效率是不是更好一點。
確實
對吧？
你像之前咱們去咱們同事那。
他們家客廳二十天。
那個小空調真的沒啥用的。
你就站在空調出門口那是涼了。
你稍微離遠一點
就完全趕不去不到涼衣。
那麼這個時候
如果立一個大批數的空調。
那多爽
但很好奇
它為什麼沒有賣的。
有知道原因的朋友們。
可以在評論區裡面給我們留言。
給我們科普一下
為什麼日本沒有這種貴市的空調賣。
雖然說日本沒有貴市的空調。
但是日本有一個特殊的空調。
叫做可移動空調
就是帶四個輪的一個小空調。
對啊？
其實你那時候說要買一個空調。
咱倆就在考慮說
二樓要不要裝一個那種移動的空調。
我覺得那東西還挺實用的。
對啊？
比如說臥室如果覺得冷的話。
就搬到書房來
反正就是哪熱搬哪去。
雖然說它智冷的面積。
肯定沒有普通的空調那麼大。
但是在一個小房間裡面。
我覺得是足夠用的了。
對
而且那個東西還挺便宜的。
就是大家可能不知道。
在日本買一個空調特別貴。
就是為什麼一直我們也沒有考慮買兩個的原因。
就在日本如果你買一個新的空調。
便宜的可能要十多萬。
貴的可能就二三十萬。
然後你找人裝的話要額外花錢。
對
找人裝和差都是要花錢的。
但是如果你要買一個。
帶四個輪的那種可移動的小空調的話。
第一個不需要人裝。
第二個那個價格可能也就是。
兩三萬三四萬日圓。
所以這就是為什麼我們其實。
有在考慮要不要買一個那種小的可移動的空調。
有可能今年我們就準備買一個。
等你在考慮好的時候。
今天夏天都過完了。
但是有一些新的這種移動空調。
它不是有智冷和智熱。
或者是這幾個模式它都有嗎。
我們可以買一個智熱是這個意思嗎。
我們就可以用它來過冬天。
其實你不覺得冬天。
咱們家反而沒有這麼難。
是啊？
是因為我們有燒燈油的爐子。
那個爐子真的很好使。
對
我今天剛還看了一個新聞。
說為什麼國內的夏天。
不能像冬天一樣有那種共暖用的暖氣片。
共冷用的冷氣片
專門是水循環的那種冷氣片。
其實可以循環冷水。
是
但是他們就發現說這個東西它智領效果。
不是特別好
而且要大面積的鋪裝。
可能需要很大的成本。
所以還是空調會更使用一些。
更方便一點吧？
那除了空調以外
其實還有很多東西。
我覺得跟國內也特別不一樣。
就是在日本到了夏天以後。
你可以看到到處都有賣那種什麼。
冷感的床單
冷感的小背
冷感的枕套
還有冷感的抱枕
哦 某某小背是吧？
這東西國內現在也有了。
它沒給廣告
其實我想來的
就是我們有一個朋友。
就前一陣我們吃飯的時候。
他跟我們說
他買了一個神器小路的小兵妹。
說這個東西特別好使。
他晚上蓋的時候都有點冷。
然後我們說
我們剛好要做一期這個節目。
就剛好我們那個朋友他有體驗過。
所以我就想著要不然找這個。
廟界的商務去要個飯。
廟界和神器小路是一家。
但是我給忘了
但其實我覺得咱們朋友就是。
買這個東西也挺神奇。
就是他是在國內買完之後。
帶到日本來用
對
我覺得這個價格雖然說。
不是特別便宜
但是相比於日本來說的話。
它價格真的不高
是
人家在日本買一個這種東西的話。
動輒就得三四千四五千。
甚至還有上萬樓的見過。
但是在國內可能
只要100多塊錢。
而且這個東西我覺得。
在國內可能是最近幾年。
才流行起來的吧？
就在以前可能睡的更多都是涼心。
頂多了就是有這個牛筋布。
牛筋布什麼東西
就是一個白色的
挺厚挺硬的
就躺上去涼涼的這麼一種布。
這個東西是田徑特有的嗎。
你北京沒有嗎
我不知道別人怎麼樣。
就是說我好像從來沒有聽說過。
也沒有用過這個東西。
因為涼心它夾肉你知道吧？
對
還夾頭髮
所以我特別不喜歡用涼心。
尤其是那種麻將的涼心。
我填那個太難受了。
就一個一個人那個。
而且那個麻將的不僅有涼心。
還有這個枕筋
要蓋在枕頭上的
但是那個的話我覺得我就更用不了了。
就架頭髮加得更厲害。
而且那種東西誰都用不了。
而且那麼硬對吧？
怎麼睡呢？
你擔心有頭髮的都用不了。
對頭髮有很多要求。
你說這個我想想
其實日本好像也沒有什麼用文章的習慣是不是。
還真的
就是我小時候晚上睡覺的時候。
我的記憶就是必須得用文章。
然後外邊點著文箱。
對
有的時候就是剛把文章四周都塞好。
然後我剛躺就聽見文章裡面有蚊子。
然後你在文章外邊睡是吧？
沒有啊？
我就在文章裡頭開著手電。
在文章裡頭找蚊子。
要不然這一晚上就別睡了。
但是好像在日本沒有。
蚊子在日本
我沒見過有用文章。
你沒見過賣蚊子
第二一個好像在日本用不著蚊子。
咱晚上睡覺沒有這麼多蚊子。
對
咱家這邊確實蚊子不怎麼多吧？
一個夏天頂多能被叮十個包座又撐死了。
那還是在外面
對
在家裡面的話
也有可能是咱們家有電文箱。
電區文業
但是不管怎麼說
在家裡面幾乎沒有見到過蚊子。
但你還真別說
之前我在刷小龍書的時候。
在網上看到很多帖子。
大家在日本都是在用文章的。
甚至還有人說這個文章我閒置了。
我不用了
他想出二手
從國內帶來的文章嗎。
不是
有的是從亞馬遜買的。
有的是從國內帶的。
反正這個蚊子的問題確實。
我來到日本以後
幾乎晚上睡覺沒有被蚊子所困擾過。
對
這個還挺好的
當然也有可能是因為最近幾年。
這個電區文業做得比較好了。
或者發展得比較快了。
其實說在國內
你要是用電區文業的話。
可能也不需要文章了。
也有這個可能
你剛說到那個涼鞋。
我就想起來
咱們倆逛街的時候。
在那個Home Center裡面看到的。
有一個類似於涼鞋的東西。
叫天津竹簾
其實我第一次看到的時候。
我以為它那個就是涼鞋。
你以為那個是涼鞋嗎。
對啊？
我以為日本人管涼鞋。
叫做天津竹簾呢？
我第一次看到的時候。
我在困惑
困惑
為什麼天津的竹簾。
在日本這麼有名
這我還真查了
它說是因為天津周邊的爐尾。
質量特別好
所以以前會從天津進口大量的這種。
優質的爐尾
然後日本人來給它編成這種竹簾。
所以它叫天津竹簾。
天津三寶
天津飯
天津飯 天津竹簾 天津版粒。
竹簾這個東西
現在可能在國內不常見了。
我就估計很少有家庭再用這個東西。
但是在我小的時候。
我確切實實是用過的。
雜的
你也跟這邊一樣是綁在陽台上的。
就是綁在陽台上一捲。
然後需要遮陽的時候。
從屋裡有個繩
你把那個繩放開
那個捲就放下來了。
其實還挺好用的
說實話
但是可能現在
因為近些年
可能國內的房
大家都封陽台了
可能這個竹簾就沒有什麼需求了。
而且現在可以用一種百頁窗。
就是更方便
而且更美觀了
但是這邊日本人
還特別喜歡用這種遮陽的竹簾。
尤其是老人
用昭和風的那種方子。
特別愛用的
或者40歲以上的這些人。
因為可能自帶一種復古的氣息。
就是一般就是綁在陽台上。
然後一端是綁在陽台的廊杆上。
就起到了一個保護隱私和遮陽的作用。
對
而且除了竹簾以外。
其實他們還有
那叫什麼戴網眼的那個布。
灰黑色的那個
類似於像牛筋布吧？
但是它是透光的
對
類似於那種
到時候可以大家看一看收納子。
可以找到照片
然後放到收納子裡。
就是這種特別復古的遮陽的東西。
其實在日本
現在還是相當流行的。
對
那說到這個簾子
其實我突然想到
就是夏天如果你要在室內避暑的話。
我覺得剛咱們說的空調。
風扇和窗簾
或者說遮陽的簾子。
它其實是一套系統。
你不覺得嗎
對都是不要讓這個房間。
接收過多的太陽光。
對
就是減少光照了之後。
整體的房間裡面
保冷效果會更好一點。
對
就是發熱會少了
所以到夏天的時候。
我們一般會把
我們現在房子自帶的一個捲聯門。
給拉下來
咱們拉捲聯門
是因為咱們家的這個窗簾。
遮光的效果確實有限。
對
不是說我們家窗簾不好。
其實我們家窗簾買的。
已經是非常貴的
我們家三個窗簾
才兩萬多日圓
它的遮光保溫的等級。
已經是在日本最高的了。
但是即使是這樣
它的遮光效果依然是很有限。
對
所以我真的是特別想吐槽一下。
日本的這種窗簾
對
就我們家買的這種。
其實已經算是日本比較少見的了。
而且賣的很貴嘛？
像是大多數在店裡頭買的。
或者是燕馬遜買的那些。
哪怕它寫的是遮光一級。
就是最高級了嘛？
但是你買回來之後。
可能它也是沒有辦法完全遮光。
也沒有辦法完全斷熱的。
對
不是因為這個窗簾本體它不遮光。
是因為這個窗簾跟牆。
它有一定的縫隙
這個光會從縫隙中露進來。
那你知道為什麼有縫隙。
是因為日本的房子。
它大多數是沒有國內那種。
窗簾合的
也就是說不管這個窗簾它有多好。
光也會從上面透出來。
所以說這就更加體現了。
我們這個捲聯門的重要性。
其實咱們家這個配置還挺好的。
每一個窗戶都配了一個捲聯門。
對
它有一定的隔熱效果。
同時它還可以百分之百的遮光。
其次就是如果有一些颱風天。
不太好的天氣的時候。
它會保護這個窗戶。
對
尤其是下冰薄的時候。
前兩天好像下冰薄了。
對
所以其實我們家現在到夏天。
是這個捲聯門配合的窗簾。
一起使用
其實它的隔熱效果還可以。
我是覺得
對
但我以前自己住的時候。
我是沒有錢買這麼貴的窗簾的。
我一般用的就是它自帶的一個窗簾。
或者是去燕馬遜
它自帶還有窗簾的。
對
它自帶一個窗簾
跟你這個顏色是一模一樣的。
我不知道房子還有自帶窗簾的。
我來那有啥也沒有。
我第一天來的時候是用床單。
真的嗎
就是百元店買的那個夾子。
我是用床單一個一個夾上。
然後掛上去的
哎
這你就是那個時候不認識我你知道嗎。
如果你要認識我的話。
我就告訴你一個小訣竅。
就是你再在百元店多買一個那種保溫毯。
就是能裹在身上保溫用的那種特別薄的那種綠的。
你把那個東西夾在你那個床單後頭。
你就可以得到一個非常簡易。
但是非常實用的保溫又遮光的窗簾。
但是那個東西不花了花了響嗎。
對啊？
但是它只要100日圓。
所以既實用又便宜。
那麼肯定就要捨棄一些東西。
就比如說它可能會有一些聲音在。
雖然說它這個遮光遮熱。
它沒有到非常好的程度。
但是肯定要比你弄好不少。
尤其是租房的話
性價比就非常的高。
但是我不怕
因為我有捲聯門
還你早說
我沒有捲聯門放下來就完了。
哎呀你早說呀我都忘了。
但是為什麼咱們家現在不把捲聯門放下來呢？
是因為我覺得每天早上起來這個陽光也挺重要的。
你每天早上起來你也不行啊？
果然是陽光的你有啥用。
行不行的
我想不想有陽光是我的事。
每天早上起來
我說把窗簾拉開
距離就跟吸血鬼劍的光一樣。
不許拉臉不要拉臉。
你以為那時候還沒醒呢？
你等我醒了之後再拉呀？
然後我說那你我給你把這個捲聯門放下來。
你不就能徹底的黑了嗎。
你不就能徹底的好好睡覺了嗎。
說不行我要藉陽光。
是因為這捲聯門如果完全拉下來了。
我們就懶得給它再拉上去了。
所以呢？
這樣的話這個房子二十四小時就都是黑的了。
它就沒有一個就是交替的感覺。
是真多了
你好煩你
就是作為一個房間它該有陽光的時候得有。
同樣的它該黑天的時候它也得黑。
所以這就是為什麼窗簾可能相對於捲聯門。
這麼重的玩意兒來說它更方便一點。
就比如說我覺得我爸媽過年的時候。
給我那個小屋子弄的那種隔熱的鋁膜。
那個勁兒也挺好的。
而且那個也很方便。
對我選擇捲聯門
還沒說完呢？
你咋呢我都選擇捲聯門。
因為那個東西它有輕。
而且比我之前用家子把保溫毯加在後邊來說的話。
它更加的方便
它更厚實
對當你沒有捲聯門的時候。
其實你爸弄的那一套東西還挺好用。
也挺方便的
其實那個就有點像那個竹旗捲上去。
然後給它放下來
對只不過它沒有那個繩子。
就是也可以弄一個那個繩子。
雖然說沒有太大的必要跟繩旗一樣。
你那個還有照片嗎。
就是你弄那個窗簾加保溫毯的那個。
有照片
我當時還特意發了小紅書呢？
是嗎
你可以把那個照片放在那裡給大家看看。
大家也可以去我小紅書瞅瞅。
你那個小紅書發點東西嗎。
發點東西以為你耗費了。
是
差不多
然後還有一個我覺得。
國內跟日本不太一樣了。
就是關於洗澡水的這個問題。
就是我在日本洗澡的時候。
長年洗澡水設置的都是42度。
當然夏天有可能會設置成40度。
但是肯定不會低於40度。
所以老飯有時候用我設置這個水溫。
有時候它進去洗澡的時候。
每次開水的時候
都可以被燙的熬一燙的。
那是冬天
其實夏天還好
夏天咱們兩個用的溫度差不多。
就現在我基本上都不用調了。
就是我們家的這個熱水。
其實是有兩套控制的。
一個是在那個面板上。
你可以精確的設置。
你要出多少水溫的水。
然後在你洗澡的時候。
有一個斑手
它是有這個刻度的。
然後你可以調冷熱水的一個比例。
每一次到了冬天的時候。
我如果不調那個冷熱水的比例。
我開一次被燙一次。
但是到了夏天以後還好。
夏天的時候我基本上就不用動你的那套東西。
對 是因為以前設置太高了。
有時候剛洗完澡
然後吹頭包的時候又會出一身汗。
就感覺這個澡好像白洗了。
但是今年夏天
我就之前看了一個視頻說。
洗澡水如果設成35度的話。
出來你就會體感覺得剛合適。
你也不會出汗了
所以我就稍微調低了一點。
你冬天也不要設置太高。
你冬天不行
也可以
冬天如果不設置這麼高。
我會覺得這個水是涼的。
它甚至都不是說溫的。
我會覺得冷
但是在國內的時候。
我洗澡不是這樣
我不知道大家可能。
有沒有跟我一樣的這種體驗。
就是我家這個調節水溫的水龍頭。
它可能過於敏感了。
你最好說的是水龍頭。
你不解釋其實沒什麼的。
就是水龍頭
但凡往左調一點點。
你就能被燙死
往右調一點
你就能被凍死
就是這個水溫
它不是我自己能控制的。
雖然說天然氣在那個刻度表上顯示的。
它燒起來其實是有一個溫度在的。
但實際傳到水龍頭。
傳到我身上的時候。
又是另外一個感覺。
我在國內洗澡調水溫的時候也很痛苦。
就是每一次找到那個中間態。
是非常隨緣寫隨機的。
對 而且這中間態。
它能保持長時間
其實你也不知道
而且你不能關上它。
你關上它以後
那個冷熱比例就有變了。
你就又得線挑
所以每次洗澡的時候。
我就是開著它
然後躲開這個水
然後去沫這個沐浴露和洗澡水。
然後再進到這個水裡面去沖。
這麼具體的畫面
也不用這樣
那在日本其實除了我們在家裡面。
可以有一個溫度自由以外。
其實在外面公共場合。
這個體感跟國內也是完全不一樣。
就是在日本任何一個室內的環境。
它會把空調開得特別大。
就是人都覺得冷
你如果待久了
必須得搭件衣服
對 你像我和雪爺去勇望。
或者說是拉拉破的商場逛街的時候。
我們如果坐到一個地兒。
去歇一會
時間長了雪爺會覺得冷。
但是在國內感覺就完全不一樣。
我們五一的時候
不是回國在酒店錄裏去節目嗎。
其實那這白天也挺樂的了。
我們錄節目那個酒店。
其實我覺得是比較好的。
但是那個酒店沒空調。
它也不是沒空調
它就是有
它不給開
但是沒到月份
對 咱也不知道為什麼。
就是我開空調需要看月份。
不是看溫度
就是只要沒有到這個月份。
沒有到夏天
真正意義上的夏天。
40度我也不開空調。
40度我覺得有點絕對了。
但是如果說是30度的話。
對 如果是30度的話。
它可能要斟酌一下。
我覺得好奇怪
就是你的房間裏面。
其實我覺得它的裝修。
都挺好的
服務也不錯
然後是那種大的落地窗。
窗名起定的都非常好。
然後到了白天
尤其到了快中午的時候。
那個大的落地窗
就倒在屋裏面
像一個陽光房一樣。
外面可能30度
屋裏面就得35、36度。
但我覺得它窗戀上。
確實挺好的
你敢買窗戀摘來拿回來用。
所以你屋裏面沒空調。
其實到了中午
其實很難受的
我們如果說白天需要出去玩。
我會覺得還好
反正我也不在屋裏待著。
但是我們那天白天要在屋裏面錄節目。
我們還不敢開電扇。
你說得得得開電扇。
我覺得它有服務做得比較好的一點。
就是它還給配了一個電扇。
說先生不好意思
我們沒有空調
但是我們可以給你一個電扇。
我們錄節目是不能開這個電扇。
就導致我們那天錄的時候。
就一邊錄
一邊抹汗
然後時不時再得停一下。
吹一吹電扇
稍微涼快了一點
然後再接著錄
整體的感受非常的糟糕。
反而我們在北京
我當時住了一個算是小旅店。
小旅館招待所了都算是。
對 就類似於這種的。
因為它裝不起裝空調。
所以它是每個房間裏單獨配了一個空調。
反而是這種單獨配的空調。
讓我住的會比較舒服。
就是我可以自由的去調節這個溫度。
我冷了我就關上空調。
我熱我就開空調
你是跟我說沒到月份不給空調。
我覺得這有點過分。
是的
而且不僅僅是酒店。
我們不是跟那個記者下班串了一期節目嗎。
當時其實是去的記者下班。
他們的那個錄音間。
那個其實算是一個創業園區了。
其實裏面配置什麼都挺好的。
那個樓它也沒有空調。
朋友們
錄音間沒有空調
因為也沒到6月份。
所以人家也不給你開。
如果說沒有空調的酒店那個房間。
像是陽光房的話
沒有空調的錄音間就相當於一個保溫箱。
你還真別說
因為它的密封隔音做的特別好。
它那個門都是兩層的。
一層普通的門
一層特別厚的門
然後裏面牆上用了各種的吸引板。
指針棉什麼東西
那些罷了
所以後來我們就只能把錄音間的。
所有的窗戶門全開開。
然後我們在這個準備間裏面先兩會天。
等那個屋裏面溫度降一降。
我們再進去錄
即使是那樣
其實在錄的時候
我這汗就一直沒斷。
這個就跟日本的體感完全不一樣。
我在日本工作的那個寫字樓。
它不管你外面多少度。
它在樓裏面的溫度是長年維持在26度的。
所以外面不管冷熱。
你在裏面都可以待得比較舒適。
像這種服務提供商。
你要給你的顧客
你要給你的用戶提供一個舒適的環境。
我覺得保持一個適宜的溫度。
是一個最基本的要求。
我到現在都覺得很離譜。
跟我說我沒有到月份。
所以沒有空調
我所
但我覺得對於他們來說。
是不是一些節能減排也同樣的重要。
所以他們可能需要兼顧這兩者之間。
節能減排你不能以犧牲用戶體驗為代價。
或者說我再陰謀論一下。
有可能就是打著這個節能減排的謊子。
就是為了省錢省電。
當然了省錢也是一部分嘛？
對
所以在這個工廠和體驗也是差別非常大。
那除了這個方式以外。
我覺得日本的地鐵也是非常值得一輸的。
就是因為日本的地鐵。
它也是不看你外面的溫度的。
當然現在可能地鐵那邊出的都是冷風。
而且它的冷氣會給的比較足一些。
但在三四月份那一天。
其實外面還有點涼。
大家穿的可能也是稍微有點厚的外套。
但是在車廂裏面
人員密度一大
再加上那個座本身就發熱。
就導致車廂裏面其實還是比較熱的。
然後我記得有一次我下班回家的時候。
我在地上正擠著呢？
我剛感覺有點熱了。
我突然感覺從頭頂傳來了一絲涼風。
那個地鐵開空調了你敢信。
就是來了剛剛好
對
就是我不知道他們具體的解決方案是怎麼樣的。
具體的運轉邏輯怎麼樣的。
但是就我的體驗二年的話。
我會覺得它可能會監測車廂內的溫度。
達到了一個值以後。
它就會開啟智冷這個模式。
把車廂的溫度控制在一個。
相對來說比較舒適的一個狀態。
你當然還好不是後背傳來了一絲涼液。
我
發現領導站後頭呢？
跟我來就我做了什麼。
然後我心就涼了
可不莫涼得透透的。
所以這個我也是覺得日本在公共場合。
做的比較人性化的一個點。
那除了在公共場合的體驗。
跟國內有很大的區別以外。
其實來了日本以後。
發現夏天連吃什麼也變。
就在國內的時候
我最期待的夏天就是吃冰鎮的西瓜。
冰鎮綠豆湯
我也是
尤其是吃完飯之後。
從冰箱拿出來那種拔好的。
要麵就是切片
然後要麵就是换著吃。
邊吃邊吹著空調風扇。
我那這甚至可以拿西瓜當飯吃。
但是西瓜的熱量還挺高的。
但是爽
夏天的時候有時候真吃不下去東西。
是
是因為你們在那環境確實也吃不下東西。
可能夏天吃的最多的就是涼麵。
還是那種帶冰蟬的。
你們還帶冰蟬的
對
我們家就是吃爸媽做的炸醬麵。
天津麵
對
西方式雞蛋麵
天津是麻醬麵
然後麵一定得是我媽做的那種手感麵。
而且必須得是過水過的。
拔涼拔涼
對
但我爸就不行
他就必須得吃鍋條。
我就不吃鍋條
我爸也吃鍋條
太熱吃下去
對
而且鍋條沒發現特別容易土。
過完涼水有特別清爽的麵。
對
所以我說一年四季都吃鍋涼水的。
然後加上黃瓜豆芽再加上炸醬。
國內是不是有一句話叫頭腐角的二伏麵。
對
咱們沒吃咬你沒吃麵。
下一句是什麼
沒有下一句
還有下一句
哦對
三伏烙餅炭雞蛋
那不出一角出二麵。
出三大元烤雞蛋嗎。
都一樣
就不管是過年還是夏天。
在北方這一套
離不開這套東西
就是餃子和麵條
可能每到一個重大的節氣。
或者節日的時候都要。
都得吃餃子
然後像我家一般是吃完了涼麵。
炸醬麵以後
來一碗綠豆湯
綠豆湯其實感覺是常備的。
我們家到了夏天
冰箱裡面永遠會有綠豆湯。
而且綠豆湯喝的時候。
在學校喝喝
在家喝也不一樣
在家喝的那個
一般都成綠豆粥了。
阿彌险你哥的豆子太多了嗎。
對
就我們家習慣可能會做得比較稠。
像粥一樣
有的時候甚至還會放點米。
當然在學校喝那個。
它就是完全沒有豆子的。
你那不叫綠豆湯
你家喝那個綠豆西飯。
綠豆粥
你說綠豆湯其實都是有點。
過的叫綠豆水
綠豆水
但是我在學校喝的時候。
特別喜歡去焯底
摟那個豆子
沒啥要啥
對
我就不愛撈底
因為你不喜歡吃那個豆子。
不是
是因為我每次去打綠豆水。
或者說自己帶的時候。
都是帶的是杯
所以你喝完了以後。
那個豆子就都沉底了。
說什麼呢？
倒我嘴裡
那東西特別容易搜。
對
你知道到了下午
我只要把那個杯打開。
那個味兒有多酸
所以我喝綠豆湯的時候。
我特別討厭撈底下那個豆。
我就想撇上面那個湯。
就撇一碗湯
喝了我就可以
再倒其他的飲料
或者倒其他的水再接著喝。
但那個湯
如果你一上午沒喝完的話。
下午它其實也容易搜。
不會的
我不知道多少人跟我一樣。
就是我喝水的方式是論杯喝。
你是水牛是吧？
我不是一口一口喝。
我是一瓶一瓶喝
打開了以後
這瓶我肯定是要喝完的。
所以不存在說
我拿了一杯東西
我可以從上午到下午。
不可能
我覺得我們家那個時候。
除了吃涼麵和西瓜之外。
我爸在看電視的時候。
我還特別喜歡吃
就是純水的那種冰棍。
叫老北京冰
那不就是冰嗎
純水的冰棍
就是水和糖
就是純水跟糖
老冰棍
對 老冰棍
老北京冰棍
我覺得應該是中階冰點。
他們家的
那時候賣五毛錢一根。
哪都有老冰棍
天津有天津的老冰棍。
北京有北京的老冰棍。
反正就是老冰棍
東北的老冰棍
其實東西都是鴨
我就特別不愛吃這個。
我喜歡吃雪糕
我喜歡吃那個紅小豆的那個。
康樂小豆
天津叫康樂小豆
其他地方我不知道。
我喜歡吃那個
還有綠色心情
綠色心情我一般
綠舌頭我愛吃
綠舌頭你愛吃
然後我小時候關於夏天的記憶。
我記得還有一段時間。
就我住在那個西城西四湖通。
那個平坊的時候
到了夏天晚上出去。
就去那個湖通狗乘涼。
然後你就能看見很多北京大爺。
躺在那個躺椅上
拿一個鋪上
拿一個大茶缸子
跟哪兒
哄悠悠的聽那廣播。
大茶缸裡面高碎
哦對
然後喝完那個還得。
啪喲
對對對
然後我記得旁邊那個新街口。
有一個那個新川麵館。
那個涼麵頭好吃
就這個店比我爸媽碎的都大。
基本上屬於是我從小吃到大的。
它那個麵其實跟自己家做的不太一樣。
它是麻醬那個地
但是味道是甜鹹口的。
那跟天津好像很像。
天津就吃麻醬麵
嗯
但它是甜鹹口的
哦
就這個味可能是出了那個店。
其他店一般不太做的一個味。
這個時候在開業北冰洋。
冰鎮的
哎呀？
這夏天就過得特別爽。
天津是山海關
那東西都是那東西啊？
哎是嗎
橘子味的汽水啊？
是嗎
對對對
你們叫山海關啊？
對
但是在日本到了夏天以後。
我就發現
它其實也是有各種麵的。
就是國內的那些東西。
可能
不太能吃得到了
或不能經常吃得到。
但是來這個店以後。
可能形成一些新的過夏天的一些習慣。
對
就是雖然它同樣都是一些涼麵。
但是味道就是日本的味道嘛？
就比如說
玉三家或者說便利店一般都會賣的。
像中華涼麵
嗯
它長得跟咱們那種涼麵差不多。
也是黃色的那種鹼水麵。
對
然後配菜也是什麼熊飾。
或者紅瓜絲啊？
雞蛋絲啊？
就這種
但是它味道就是日式酸甜口的那種味。
其實我不太吃
我覺得很奇怪這個味道。
其實你要給它換上麻醬的話就得好吃了。
或者說
你知道嗎
它那個中華涼麵裡面。
如果你放一瓶雪壁。
那就變成嚴激冷麵的類似於那個味道。
那種味就特別像了。
再切兩片蘋果
再來一個雞蛋
就很像了
但是麵不是那個麵。
對
麵差一點
然後還有一種就是冷喬麥麵。
我覺得也挺好吃的。
我最愛吃的其實就是冷喬麥。
我覺得冷喬麥
怎麼說呢？
又健康又清爽
就是啥也沒有唄
雖然說它的味道比較寡淡。
但是吃下去以後
尤其在夏天就會感覺格外的清爽。
格外的好吃
我們家附近其實有一個祖傳的喬麥館。
對
這之前我們也介紹過。
所以有的時候我們到了夏天。
就會去那吃
其實不光是冷喬麥。
我覺得冷烏冬也挺好吃的。
尤其是乾橘味的那種。
這個話你應該不太吃。
我不太吃
就因為我不愛吃烏冬這種麵型。
就是味道在各一邊。
就是烏冬那種比較粗的。
比較Q彈的
但是說軟又不是特別軟的。
有點彈彈的那種感覺。
我嚼起來會費勁
它像是麻薯
但比麻薯要硬一點。
你知道像啥
像四川的甜水麵
甜水麵比它好吃多了。
不是
我說它的嚼感有點像甜水麵。
就是你得想著要固定住麵。
然後去咬斷它
不然的話它可能會隨時的滑走。
所以我就特別不喜歡吃這種麵。
我吃完了感覺塞幫子累的。
你這個牙口不太行。
不是
我要去非常用力且有捕捉感的去嚼它。
還有捕捉感
就是你得把它固定在你牙齒中間。
要不然它又會跑掉。
對
所以我特別不愛吃這個。
就是之前爸媽來了。
咱不如去吃了一個碗硅脂麵。
就是那個吃的我就有點累的。
但我還行
尤其是你像這個柑橘味的這個冷的霧凍的話。
一般它裡面除了這個柑橘以外。
它還會有一些蘿蔔泥。
它同樣也是沒有什麼味道。
但是就是特別的清爽。
而且我覺得這個季節還特別適合吃。
就是流水素麵
就比如說我們去年大冬天。
在九州那個高千歲峽谷裡面吃的那個。
其實那個甜我覺得不是很好吃實話。
就是冬天給我們吃那個流水素麵凍得透心涼。
但是那個如果放在現在的話。
你會覺得數不少
因為它有那個水
在那個環境裡本身就會有一種清涼感。
就是有那種水流的聲音。
但是放在大冬天的話。
那就是凍的藥瓷
當然了你其實還可以買一個。
塑料的流水素麵的機器。
自己在家裡做是嗎。
哎
這回頭如果咱們家有那些空間的話。
可以買一個試試
要這種生活的儀式感。
我就不撈出來直接沾水吃。
我就得放在那裡頭。
還得玩一玩
然後除了這些面類。
其實我覺得這邊到了夏天。
就是大家還特別喜歡吃鰻魚。
我剛想說
除了這些冷的東西以外。
我現在鰻魚算是一個比較異類的夏天的事物。
對
尤其是最近就是一個非常適合吃鰻魚的日子。
每年到了其實夏天都是吃鰻魚的人。
咱也不知道為什麼。
這個其實我也查了。
你又查了
那你說吧？
你都查了
就是它不是有一個說吃鰻魚的一個專屬的日子。
叫土用醜日
就有這麼一個習俗。
所謂這個土用
土地的土用就是有用的用。
就是比如說
麗春麗夏麗秋麗冬。
之前半個月叫土用。
就是一個過渡的感覺。
然後這個醜日其實就是乾脂。
那個紫薯醜的那個醜日。
所以它就是醜日12天會循環一次。
所以在這個土用半個月之內。
如果碰見了一個醜日。
那麼叫土用醜日
就比如說8月7號馬上就要麗秋了。
那麗秋好多麗秋了嗎。
可不嗎
可年紀呢？
正直
正下
就是麗秋是解氣的概念。
但是溫度其實是它不太跟著這個走的。
所以26號就是一個土用醜日。
就特別是吃鰻魚
但是為什麼要吃鰻魚呢？
是因為剩下它沒有什麼胃口。
所以以前日本人會覺得說。
在這種換季的期間。
吃一點這種滋補類的東西會比較好。
那麽同時醜日它這個發音是無適之。
所以日本人會認為在這一天吃烏開頭的食物。
就比如說烏納基鰻魚。
比如說烏冬
比如說烏梅
就是梅子
會比較的極力
同時比較的滋補
然後最後是因為商業宣傳的一個原因。
所以鰻魚就從這個。
所有的烏開頭的食物裏面脫穎而出。
就跟這個土用醜日綁定了。
於是現在就到了夏天。
這麽一個季節就特別說吃鰻魚。
你知道這像啥嘛？
你形容完這一套
像啥呢？
就像國內吃肝明目。
吃哪補哪
那吃肝怎麽會明目呢？
對呀？
吃豬腦還補腦子呢？
吃肝不應該補肝嘛？
不知道呀？
就是你說的這個套東西。
我完全不知道呀？
反正就是每一個國家都有自己一套。
這麽個進補的邏輯。
對
但是我會覺得國內的進補科學一點。
它肯定是跟著中華養生的一套走的。
對
我甚至還想去學一學。
到了某一個季節
然後去做一些資補類的食物。
應記的
就比如說甚至是什麽排骨山藥。
或者說是什麽羊肉。
什麽類似於這種燉的那種湯。
什麽沉皮
什麽水
什麽遮納
廚師的那種
對
我會覺得它很有道理。
但是你說的這個
就很堅強
烏鎧頭的東西
我就會覺得有點莫名其妙的。
有點堅強
是因為它跟那個發音。
同樣都是嗚
對
這不就是那種吃啥補啥的。
但是拋開這部壇
我是覺得
鰻魚就有點挺好吃。
對
鰻魚吃多容易膩
所以它其實也是說。
就像這種進補類的。
可能也不太適合天天吃。
日日吃
就是食不食的吃一下。
進補一下
那麽大部分的夏天。
其實還是要通過這些涼麵。
或者是涼爽的食物去度過。
所以除了鰻魚
其實還有很多的小涼菜。
尤其是居酒屋裡面一般可能會有。
這個涼炭其實年四季都有。
只不過到了夏天
大家吃的會比較多一些。
對
除了這種冷凍毛豆。
什麽豆腐之外
有一個
我覺得是夏天獨有的。
啥
就是景點和街上一般會賣。
那種炎字的
整根的黃棍
那個東西巨難吃
真的巨難吃
你經常可以在
夏日記的小攤和景點裏面看到。
同時你也經常可以在景點的地上看到。
就是因為它難吃
我都恨不得就是
你不要給我字一下。
你就把新鮮黃給我就行。
我都會覺得那個不錯。
就拿冷水泡一下
然後你就直接給我就可以了。
對
因為雖然它看起來是在冰水裏面。
泡著的一個冰鎮的黃瓜。
實際你吃的時候它非常的鹹。
而且一根要賣你500日圓。
雖然我覺得它很難吃。
但是我能理解他們的這個邏輯。
就是在日本
他們在夏天會特別看重鹽分的補充。
對
因為有賣那什麽鹽分補充。
糖嘛？
你看到處都有
什麽那種硬糖
有那種VC和鹽的。
然後飲料也有
吃的東西也是
他們會著重去宣傳。
這個是給身體補充鹽分。
補充水分的類似於這種。
我覺得割一點鹽
我可以接受
因為畢竟出汗多了。
容易墊你吃虹
你補點鹽分很正常。
對不對
但是那鹽自黃瓜有點太鹹了。
其實你吃一口的時候。
就跟鹹菜差不多了。
那那東西應該怎麽吃嘛？
怎麽吃
買一瓶水
買一根黃瓜
黃瓜插水瓶裡頭
然後喝那個水
那你直接去喝那鹽水不得了嗎。
還有那黃瓜幹嘛？
就是連涮涮的黃瓜。
哦嗨
到那個水喝完了以後。
然後你再吃那個黃瓜。
所以就如果你在街上不小心。
你買了一根
你就會得到一個非常難吃。
但是有沒有地兒扔的東西。
對大家如果看到那個的話。
我覺得大家不要輕易嘗試。
也不要覺得那種很清爽。
那種很厚鹹厚鹹的。
但你知道你在逛街的時候。
如果是鹽鹽夏日在街上。
看到了一個桶裡邊。
全是冰
冰鎮的黃瓜
上面還有檸檬
你會覺得哇
你要是不買的話
簡直就是虧了
其實我真覺得它可以做成兩個。
一個是鹽字的
一個就是普通冰鎮的。
我覺得那冰鎮的硬比鹽字的賣得快。
但日本人不可能為了你。
變成這兩個斑斓
下次咱倆去那擺攤。
那就擺一個清水
真的
然後結果日本人吃完這投訴你。
說你這位人不鹹
旁邊放了那個一小袋鹽。
你們累吃鹹的自己撒。
這還挺個性化
日本人夏天還有一個特別有夏天氛圍的。
一個冷飲
就是脖子汽水
脖子汽水
這個東西其實
有一個場景是我現在想到脖子汽水。
就會在腦海中浮現出來的。
什麼呢？
就是在夏日記那種夜市裡頭。
然後一個大的冰桶裡面。
插了好多脖子汽水。
旁邊一個冰桶裡面。
插了好多冰鎮黃瓜。
你喝的時候就買一個。
然後一堆
就我第一次
我說不知道脖子汽水是什麼。
後來我買了一個才知道。
它原來裡面是有一個玻璃豬的。
那東西就是色素糖水。
它有色素
有
有不同的味道
不同的膳
我其實不太愛喝那東西。
但是那東西就非常有夏天的儀式感。
對
就是
嘣
那一下
你開啤酒也是那個嘣。
開啤酒不是
開啤酒是
這麼專業呢？
那脖子汽水是你把那個東西頂進去嗎。
然後那個玻璃豬就到了那個。
凹進去的那一塊
最後的水就通過那個玻璃豬。
再流到你的嘴裡了。
我就會覺得那個非常有夏天的儀式感。
就我第一次喝的時候。
我只覺得它新鮮
因為瓶子我覺得挺好看的。
但喝了之後我發現我不太喜歡那個味道。
然後就再不買了
那其實就是香精的味。
你說到香精
其實夏日記它上還有一個東西。
就是爆冰
日本那個爆冰
就跟我小的時候
四五歲吃的那爆冰一樣的。
全是色素
對
就是色素糖精
然後調的那個
那算是醬料嘛？
咱都不能醬料
就是水
對就是水
它甚至連什麼豆子什麼的。
可能都比較少
全部都沒有
對
就全是色素
這個冰可能都不是那種。
什麼純水做的冰
不可能純水做的冰。
爆出來那個冰還特別粗糙。
這個一個其實也得好幾百。
七八百得
就是提起爆冰
就是我特別看不上日本的爆冰。
這樣嗎
就是天津的爆冰相當全味的。
我跟你們講
所以我特別想吃天津的爆冰。
你上次回又沒吃啊？
又沒吃啊？
說到這個特別氣
但是我特別喜歡吃。
就是去年咱們去那個。
九州路玩島的時候。
吃的那個白熊爆冰。
那個太甜了
那個
因為它有煉乳的底。
所以我覺得特別好吃。
它上面很好吃
但是越吃越甜
那個有點像天津的綿綿冰。
它就是爆出來特別細的冰。
然後上面撒上煉乳。
那東西其實我不喜歡吃。
因為怎麼說呢？
吃爆冰是一種很清爽。
很夏天很清涼那種感覺嘛？
但是如果你吃那種綿綿冰的話。
就是反而會給這個冰增添那一些甜膩感。
這種甜膩感跟夏天。
我覺得不是很搭
那你吃綠蛇豆的時候。
不也會有這樣的感覺嗎。
綠蛇豆是水果冰淇淋。
因為綠蛇豆
你總感覺是好像有一個人。
你可以了
停再說就不能播了。
可以了
停
對吧？
那不是冰棍有泥
那是泥油泥
你這個要去分開
你包括吃那個什麼。
各種紅小豆什麼的。
那都是那都是雪糕質地的嘛？
對紅小豆這個東西。
我更愛吃那種豆香味。
但反而你像是什麼那種。
巴喜的那種冰淇淋。
或者說是什麼巧樂汁呀？
什麼四個圈啊？
四個圈
能聽懂四個圈的朋友們。
知道為什麼我們在這兒笑的朋友們。
一定是肥化連篇的中式聽眾。
類似於這種
我覺得它有一些膩。
那可能是我個人偏好的問題。
我特別喜歡吃那種奶味的。
你跟我媽的口味其實要媽特別愛吃。
對
我媽是一口水果冰淇淋都不吃的。
她只吃那種高奶的。
而且你沒發現嘛？
就是711的那個水果冰淇淋。
特別好吃
它沒有其他那種水果冰淇淋。
那種香精的那種假甜的那種感覺。
反而是它也有一種水果的清爽感。
我就感覺它真的是拿水果做的。
那種感覺
它看起來好像就是拿水果做的。
因為裡面的骨肉切切吃的。
跟我們平常吃到的。
是差不多的
你還記得之前他們買過那個。
陶的
對
它裡面是有陶的清香味的。
咱們一會就可以買一個。
我覺得可以
因為陶的時候我在不吃的。
它就過濟了
馬上禮藥下來了是不是。
對
而這個我覺得也是日本。
非常有特色的也沒發現嘛？
雖然說在日本
蔬菜或者水果裡面比較貴。
但是它的季節感會非常的明顯。
其實潛台詞就是你不能一年四季。
想吃什麼買什麼
對
這個就是物資比較匱乏。
所帶來的一個好處。
就是你會對這個季節抱一種儀式感。
對
其實就是物以西為貴。
沒有什麼
你就特別想在這個季節吃什麼。
對
它跟國內那種季節感是不一樣。
國內是我倒著這個季節。
這個東西會變得特別的便宜。
就可以撒了花的吃。
但是其他季節也有。
只不過相對的貴一些。
對
但在日本是其他季節你看不見。
就比如說陶吧？
比如說西瓜吧？
就是這幾個東西
如果比如說過了八月份。
如果它下架了
那麼再一次看到它就明年的這個時候了。
對
所以我們經常在光超市的時候。
如果能看到不一樣的水果出現了。
就代表可能到了某一個季節了。
又該到吃這個的時候了。
所以這個時候可能就會。
一兩週吃這麼幾次。
就集中了吃
所以像我個人的體驗的話。
就會更珍惜它出現在市場上的這個時間。
嗯
其實我覺得這種東西變成了一種季節的儀式感。
它不光是夏日了
每一個季節都有屬於每一個季節的味道。
其實我在來日本之前。
或者跟你在一塊之前。
我是沒有這種感覺的。
你光超市沒有這麼明顯的。
我不愛吃水果
我除了西瓜以外
我所有的水果都不愛吃。
所以其實我來了日本以後。
對於我來說體感上沒有太大的問題。
就是第一口拜吃水果。
第二口拜吃蔬菜
我只愛吃肉
我還只愛吃雞肉
但在日本雞肉也足夠便宜。
那你好適合來日本。
反而是跟你在一塊以後。
我就會對每一個季節的東西會額外的關注。
就是說又到了吃這個的雞。
又到了吃那個的季節。
就好像生活的儀式感會更加的重。
就比如說現在是8月。
其實梨已經差不多下來了。
再過個一兩週
梨會越來越多
桃會越來越少
對
所以這兩週
我們只要看見的比較好的桃子。
我們都會買來嚐一嚐。
對
然後再過一陣
其實巨蜂
還有那個秦王普透就該下來了。
包括還有皮吧什麼的。
對
但是我們在這說一下。
就是我們買的這個桃。
還沒有肥化蓮片的肥節。
買的那個桃這麼貴。
沒有
沒有100多一顆。
對
人民幣
沒有100多人民幣一顆。
在298
221里
那個有點太貴了
我們買的這個桃
其實也不算便宜了。
30人民幣一顆
對
兩個是1500
咱倆買的最貴的
就兩個1500
對
兩個1500的話。
現在就是60塊錢。
對
就是那個已經很好吃了。
我是覺得
雖然我很想嘗嘗
連100多塊錢一顆。
那個桃到底是啥事。
而且我們倆現在有一個意識。
就是因為我們倆吃的會比較少。
就可能這一個夏天。
只吃那麼一次
或者兩次
所以我們就額外的。
會注重一些品質
對
所有貓會買一些精品的水果。
當然精品的最貴就1500了。
普通的市場是這樣的。
當然如果你倒了
比如說伊士丹富一樓。
那我應該不會去買。
那個就很貴了
或者說三四千日圓。
一個的桃子
其實也都是有的
對
所以桃子和西瓜的季節要過去了。
梨和葡萄的季節要來了。
就是秋天要來了
你說到這個西瓜
其實日本吃西瓜
它有個習慣就是
有時候會撒鹽嘛？
在國內也有
在國內也有嗎
我小時候就聽過
你聽過你這麼做過嗎。
沒有
對吧？
我第一次看那個
是看的那個
多萊艷夢
那不還是日本的
有一節他就是吃那個西瓜撒鹽。
然後我發現我身邊好多小夥伴們。
他們都嘗試過
是嗎
給我的反饋都是撒鹽以後。
西瓜變得更甜
那我們為什麼不撒呢？
我覺得有點邪修
或者就是你覺得鹽跟西瓜。
在你這兒是不搭的。
對
甚至我到現在
我就覺得酸野
我覺得很奇怪
其實我覺得是OK的。
就是另外一種風味。
辣椒面拌水果
啥味呢？
它這個水果不能是特別。
甜的那一類
有點發生的那種
對 有點酸口的
或者清芒類似於這樣的。
其實拌牛肉果都是好吃的。
牛肉果我是最不愛吃的東西。
牛肉果我真的不愛吃。
我不知道那東西吃的。
它的意義是什麼
我最愛吃了
咱們倆居然有不一樣的地方。
在吃上居然已經有分歧了。
你說這個其實來日本之後。
還有一個習慣
就是開始喝這種冷泡茶了。
冷泡茶
其實是咱們兩個沒有這個習慣。
好多南方的朋友們。
他們是有這個冷泡茶的習慣。
對 就是咱倆是來了日本之後。
才開始泡這種冷泡茶。
比如說日本這邊的冷泡茶。
一般就是大麥茶
或者說是玉米茶
冷泡一下會特好喝。
但是我們除了這些。
還會額外泡什麼呢？
還會沖酸梅湯
當然那個酸梅精是我們國內買的。
可能在南方地區有酸梅湯的東西嗎。
有的也是酸梅精是從網上買的。
但是也有一些是開的那個中藥。
然後要回去熬見
其實天津的酸梅湯和北京的酸梅湯不一樣。
咱們倆現在喝的這個是北京酸梅湯。
還以烙的酸梅湯都這味兒其實。
但是它不是天津的酸梅湯。
天津你們是什麼個習俗。
首先天津的酸梅湯一定是去藥房抓的。
就是我剛說的那種要熬的。
對 第二個天津的酸梅湯裡面必須有酸梅膏。
酸梅膏類似於像酸梅精嗎。
不是 是這種粉狀的固體的。
塊狀的 然後熬完了以後是那種帶細渣子的。
它不是現在咱們喝的那種酸梅湯特別清涼清爽的那種。
它裡面是帶渣的
怎麼讓我想起之前買過的一個山西的酸藻麵呢？
有點像那個東西
對 你還偏偏別說。
就是固體 然後依依水周變成稍微有點膏狀的粉狀的。
對 有點像那個東西。
天津的酸梅湯是一定要加酸梅膏的。
而且天津的爆冰裡面也得加酸梅膏。
所以這就是為什麼老師爆冰那麼好吃是吧？
酸梅膏是靈魂
酸梅膏是天津夏天的靈魂。
大麥茶和玉米茶就是日本夏天的靈魂。
真的是 我也不知道為什麼。
大麥茶一年四季都有。
但格外的在夏天我就會特別想喝它。
還有就是最近咱們倆研發了冷泡咖啡。
冷泡咖啡是咱們朋友告訴咱們的。
我們倆就開始不知道還能冷泡咖啡。
因為我們倆個比較懶。
對 所以我們之間買了很多咖啡豆。
讓它過期了
也不知道過期吧？
就是沒有那個香味了。
對 它的香味有點流失了。
它沒有這麼香了
所以這個豆子現在聞起來就有一股煙灰缸的味。
那個豆子是因為太沉了。
咱們家那個新豆子還可以。
就是雖然說它的那個香味。
已經沒有剛買來的時候這麼好了。
但是它還是有一些香味的。
然後咱們那個朋友來了以後。
就跟我們說
其實你這個沉的咖啡。
你可以磨成比較粗的顆粒。
然後放到茶包裡面冷泡。
我說這好呀？
剛好
我們家還有冷水桶。
丟了這麼一包兩包的。
直接弄到冰箱裡面。
想喝就隨時喝
非常方便 非常好喝。
所以我們家最近就有好幾種這個冷飲。
冷泡茶
冷酸梅湯
冷咖啡
冷牛奶
其實我們這種應該屬於是中日結合了吧？
對 我覺得這個就是咱們來了以後的一個。
最大的一個變化
就是這個也是帶著咱們國內的習慣。
融入到了日本的生活以後的一個狀態。
但也不是完全日本人的那一套習慣。
因為我們確實習慣不了他們這些東西。
確實
他們有很多東西我是吃不慣的。
就比如說他們那個透明果凍我就不愛吃。
你說那個水洋羹嗎。
對 我就會覺得很奇怪那些東西。
我跟妳說做的特別好那種水洋羹。
不僅是透明的
它的配色和圖案也是特別講究的。
我知道
就是好看
它不好吃
對呀？
我買來是吃的
我買來不是供著看的。
它做的再好看它都不好吃。
那除了這個吃以外。
其實還有很多其它的配飾。
裝飾吧？
我以前是沒有觀察過這些東西的。
這個東西我真的就是。
跟你在一塊兒以後才會去觀察到。
那你是跟我在一起以後。
對生活這些洞察裡變得更敏感了嗎。
你不能這麼說
我可以說是
我跟你在一塊兒之前。
我是活著
就一個人活著
對這個世界可能怎麼變。
跟我們什麼太大的關係。
我關心的只是我演不前的這個。
上班 掙錢 吃飯。
就在一塊兒以後才會對這個生活。
當中的一些小細節。
或者小配食才開始。
有了一些觀察和注意。
就比如說
風靈這個東西
風靈國內其實也用表度。
在以前這個東西
我知道有
但是與我無關
它什麼季節
什麼時候該掛出來。
我從來不關心這個東西。
但是跟你在一塊兒以後。
尤其咱們逛了那些飾品店。
或者物品店的時候。
就到了這個夏天的時候。
你就會發現
他們會把這個風靈掛出來。
就在這個店裡面
聽到浪的這種想
會給你帶來一種
假裝清涼的這種體感。
對 然後還會掛在一些神社。
或者是水池的旁邊。
對 它不會真的讓你感覺到涼爽。
但是你聽到那個清脆的那個聲音。
就會讓你精神上
感覺到一絲的涼意。
我覺得尤其是風靈一響。
就好像是夏天吹過來這個風。
它是有了一個
明顯的意象的
有了一個清晰的意象。
而且可能剛來的時候。
對於類似於這種飾品。
可能更多的是
日本的這個東西好好看。
這個東西很新鮮
但是逐漸的
隨著咱們融入了這個日本的生活以後。
這個東西就變成了夏天來了。
秋天來了 冬天要來了。
對 這個我其實也有提。
就是我剛來的時候買過一款。
那個波羅味的
深藍絲的包裝上面。
有花口圖案的一款。
那個喉嚨幼蟻
然後當時我會覺得。
這個設計的特別好看。
也非常的日本
然後看起來也比較涼爽。
因為它是藍色的
但是後來發現
日本幾乎每一天夏天。
都會出現一些類似的特定元素。
就是感覺這些東西已經從。
這些東西好日本變成了。
這些東西好夏天
對 後來才會發現。
原來他們比較注重這種季節感。
所以每一個季節都會有。
這個季節該出現的一些東西。
對
而且你沒發現
其實很多的商場或者說那種。
遊玩的場所
它會有這種流水的聲音。
對
還有一些噴泉
或者是水物的裝置。
對
就是這種東西會算是物理降溫嗎。
算的
其實我覺得這應該算是。
三種方式的降溫
就是物理降溫和視覺降溫。
還有就是心理上的降溫。
精神降溫
就是全方位立體式的打擊。
是嗎
對
360度無死角
所以就會有一種
獨特的夏天的儀式感。
或者這個不能叫做儀式感。
就是夏天該有的樣子。
夏天就是要有這些風鈴。
流水聲
噴泉
類似於這種東西
就像在國內
夏天就要有西瓜
冰棍
綠豆湯
冷麵
但是有一個東西是共通的。
國內國外全世界都一樣。
我覺得
歐美有嗎
我不知道
歐美有
有在歐美
可以告訴我們到底有沒有。
就是這個蟬鳴
這個蟬
真的我就是從小聽到的。
但是好像感覺
日本的蟬鳴跟國內的蟬鳴。
不太一樣
甚至像國內各個地方的。
蟬鳴的聲音也不一樣。
哦
你對這個還很有研究嗎。
蟬鳴含蟬鳴其實是。
哇
你太嚇人了
日本的蟬鳴是這個意思。
不是
那個就透氣是涼了。
你知道
這個東西我也是
你算是主觀感受或者意想。
但是我在網上看到過相關的帖子。
他們好多人都說
各個地方的蟬鳴的聲音是不一樣的。
有什麼樣的區別呢？
就是聲音的大小
或者說音調的高低的節奏也都不一樣。
那可能就是每個地方。
它的這個品種不一樣。
有可能
就是蟬鳴也是有方言的。
哦
哈哈哈哈
咋的
就你外邊這些
他們說的是日語
日語蟬
那為什麼他在跟那叫。
你現在聽不懂呢？
不是蟬有蟬語
在蟬鳴裡面
他們有方言
他們有日本蟬鳴的聲音。
有天津的聲音
有北京的聲音
有東北的聲音
有南方的聲音
天津說最
哈哈哈哈
天津蟬怎麼說話是吧？
那不是啊？
他們估計
他們蟬之間如果開會的話。
估計也得有這個問題。
你知道吧？
哦
但是我跟你說
我就特別喜歡在夏天聽蟬鳴。
像白噪音一樣
不是
也不是說這個蟬鳴聽起來。
有多麼的美妙
但是
如果聽到外邊有蟬鳴的話。
它會凸顯室內的涼爽。
這是個什麼感覺
就是蟬鳴一叫
代表外邊溫度是起來的。
那麼我在室內
又可以吹著空調
吃著西瓜蓋著棉被。
就能凸顯室內的涼爽。
反差
對
所以我以前就特別喜歡聽這種蟬鳴。
哦
哇賽你這個點
我確實也沒想到
聽蟬鳴
我在屋裡涼
所以我就涼爽
那是不是有可能
就是你已經在屋裡涼爽。
在屋裡當然涼爽
但是聽完蟬鳴的時候。
更加凸顯了這種涼爽。
如果你說
夏天聽蟬聲有一種格外的儀式感。
我會覺得
那沒有
非常的有格調
想多了
我不知道有沒有人聽過這句話。
就是春聽鳥聲
夏聽蟬聲
秋聽蟲聲
冬聽雪聲
白晝聽奇聲
月下聽蕭聲
山中聽松風聲
水際聽內乃聲
有文化
對啊？
所以我才說
如果你說
夏天聽蟬聲
有一種格外的儀式感。
會覺得
不一樣的體感
那你想多了
有內涵
你跟我來一句
我夏天聽蟬聲
在屋裡感覺到涼爽。
我會覺得
你是不是在屋裡
就是感覺到涼爽
有沒有這個蟬聲
你在屋裡都感覺到涼爽。
但只是現在覺得更涼爽。
尤其你知道
這個蟬鳴中午跟下午。
或者是晚上
它叫的聲音高低是不一樣的。
越熱叫的調得越高。
對啊？
所以在晚上睡覺的時候。
外邊那個剛剛好的產明。
如果外面不叫了
就會覺得不行
屋裡熱了
它在晚上的時候
它不是一直叫
它是溫溫的
就是時不時的會叫兩聲。
這個時候可能是更加。
是熱時冷
是那意思幹嘛？
熱了叫兩聲
又是不熱了就不叫了。
不是
討厭
我剛剛要說什麼
我都忘記了
就是夜晚的這個產明可能。
更多的是一種白噪音的作用。
那不就是白噪音了。
更多的是白噪音的作用。
但是同時它也凸顯了外邊。
是比較熱的
就是你用這個纏聲來判斷外面。
熱還是不熱
外邊熱你就覺得涼。
也不是對
也不是不行
就是你這個是通過對比。
對方越慘
你覺得自己越幸福。
我沒用對方越慘
那纏就活在那
那對
就是外邊越熱
你覺得自己越涼
對啊？
同樣都二三度
外面如果是二十五度。
你就會覺得自己熱。
外面如果是三十二度。
你就會覺得好涼爽。
是那我可以做嗎
你這皮革在拳了
太有節目效果了
我是蓋得不到你這個纏。
但是我可以大概理解。
就是因為我有同樣的感受。
不是因為聽到纏
不是因為纏教的越歡。
我越涼
是因為
是因為到了夏天以後。
日本這一邊
它會有一種特殊的氛圍感。
就是不管是超市也好。
還是外面夜市
或者馬茨蒂也好
它們都會擺出來
或者掛出來
或者食物的外包裝上。
都會有很多夏日的元素。
就比如我剛說的這種。
喉嚨有一項深藍色的包裝。
包括花火的圖案
就是即使它味道上。
沒有什麼太大的區別。
都是這些東西
但是它會通過換一個包裝。
來給顧客一種不一樣的視覺體驗。
我覺得每到看見這種。
比較清涼的這種設計的時候。
我的視覺感受上也會比較的清爽。
對
就比如說還有一些包裝上。
它可能有時候會印一些。
水氣或者氣泡的圖案。
這個你就讓我想到什麼你知道嗎。
就是小時候看那個電視上。
賣飲料那種廣告
然後開頭有一個人說。
這個天太熱了什麼的。
突然它就看到了一款飲料。
然後啪打開喝的一口。
就會很爽
對 然後喝的時候。
它還得配上那種
特別解渴和舒爽的表情。
和配音
對
所以其實在日本這邊。
我覺得物理手段降低溫度。
只是其中的一個環節。
或者一個組成部分。
它通過這種視覺的設計。
聽覺的設計
以及這個東西反映到。
你心裡的作用
全方位的給你來降溫。
給你一種夏天的清涼感。
但我覺得前提
是人得在室內有空調的地方。
你叫夏天的那個馬茨梨。
它有的地方是有噴的那種水霧的。
特別細的水霧的
或者那種地方也非常的舒爽。
對
就你得人在這種處於一個非常涼爽。
或者是比較舒適的前提之下。
那麼你看到這些東西。
才會更加的覺得比較的清涼。
但如果你是炎炎夏日看了它。
你可能只會覺得好熱。
就是主觀的物理以上的降溫是需要的。
但是它通過視覺聽覺或者心理。
給你全方位的來一個降溫。
就是把這種夏日的清涼感給凸顯出來了。
所以這個其實跟咱們所認知上的日本。
比較注重儀式感還是相通的。
我是覺得
當我們在日本生活了這麼多年以後。
我們就會發現
日本的這種看似多餘的儀式感。
會使得我們在生活中。
對於每一個季節
都有了屬於自己的味道。
屬於自己的顏色
甚至屬於自己的一個聲音。
它不只是一個天氣。
不只是一個季節了。
它變成了一種生活節奏。
就比如說咱們剛才提到的。
這個季節我們到了吃桃子的季節了。
我們到了吃西瓜的季節了。
那麼隨著桃子和西瓜的夏式。
我們就來期盼著
梨和颶風葡萄的上市。
它看似變成了一種有規律的節奏感。
那我們對待這種夏日的一些特殊的活動的感受。
也有了一些變化
就比如說花火大會這個東西。
其實我跟雪梨在一塊之前。
我只去過一兩次的花火大會。
那我自己去的時候。
可能是抱著一種嚮往新鮮。
日本的花火大會特別有名的一個活動。
特別的日本
然後我自己去完了以後覺得。
我為什麼要去
你不覺得花火很好看嗎。
但是太擠了
太熱了
所以你之前去的這兩次是沒有買門票的。
我自己的時候我想。
我為什麼看花火要花錢。
就只是找了一個免費的地方去看。
對
我就整個人體驗非常的糟糕。
後來我就不看花火大會了。
沒有我覺得那有意思。
就每年都是這些東西。
每年都放這些花
還有就是夏日季
夏日季也是第一次去特別新鮮。
你看這湊熱鬧的還有夜市。
過去看了以後
這個攤是亞基索吧？
那個攤是炎字皇過。
下一個攤是什麼整個蘋果的那個。
蘋果糖
然後再有就是香蕉的果著巧克力的那個。
玩的遊戲也是這個撈金魚。
那個設計第一個新鮮。
第二個還這個
第三個還這個
第四個不去了
沒意思
我必須連我都知道那裡面有什麼。
我就開始去夏日季的時候。
就特別選去大阪的天神祭。
是因為我覺得它是日本的三大祭之一。
但就是人特別多
人特別多是阻礙我去這種地方。
非常重要的一個原因。
但我第一次去看這個花火大會的時候。
我而覺得這個觀感和這個體驗。
還是非常好的
是因為我買票了
沒有花錢的不是
也不是
也不完全是
雖然說這個觀看的體驗非常好。
包括我到現在為止。
看過這麼大大小小很多個。
也是給我留下來很深刻的印象。
但當時就是人非常多。
然後又熱又急
最後中暑了
聽過之前第六期的朋友們。
可能也都知道我之前的一個經歷。
所以我會覺得在肉體的體驗上是非常遭罪的。
雖然說我後來也去過很多個花火大會。
但是慢慢的也就不是說所有的花火就都去了。
因為有一些就比如說像前一陣剛結束的。
那個裕田川那個阿霍。
我看了一下網上那個新聞。
他說是有100萬人去看。
那個我16年的去過一次。
你16年的10年前了。
你知道體驗是我來日本10年間。
最糟糕的一次花火大會。
就是因為人太多了。
人太多樓太多啥也看不見。
免費的地方那肯定就是前面有很多遮擋。
對
所以最開始的時候。
其實就抱著一種遊客心態來的。
你看什麼都新鮮看什麼廣場餐廳。
然後來了以後就感覺就這我為什麼要去。
然後後來
就開始買票了嗎
也不是
後來跟你在一塊兒以後。
對生活的這種儀式感逐漸的變強了。
你看說了好多次儀式感。
其實就是更加的善於去觀察生活。
或者說是從活著變成了開始生活。
那麼到這個時候
其實就會有一些不一樣的感覺。
就是我這個季節就要去做這些事。
比如像咱倆現在不可能不會去說。
每年我都要看12345678個花火。
但是一定會看這麼一到兩個。
對
而且挑這麼一到兩個花火。
或者是夏日記的時候。
一定得是那種精品的。
值得去的
或者是它有一些特殊的體驗的。
對
就像咱們吃那個桃子一樣。
就到這個季節
我們就要吃桃子
可能我沒有很愛吃桃子。
但是到這個季節到這個時間段。
作為這個季節的一個標誌。
作為一個生活的儀式感。
我也會去嘗一嘗
我甚至可以說買一個好的一點的桃子。
去嘗一嘗
所以就是花火大會和夏日記其實也是。
我可以每年我只去一個。
但是這一個可能就是為了給我的夏天一個交代。
就是我認真的過了這個夏天。
我有認真的對待這個季節。
不過我覺得我們選的這些花火大會。
也都挺有自己的特色的。
就比如說之前咱們10月份去的那個自稱的花火。
它其實跟都內或者是市裡頭一般主流的花火的體驗。
是不一樣的
就因為我們當時是搬著椅子。
然後坐在田間地頭。
一個免費的地方去看這個花火。
而且前面都沒有人。
都是地
就是整體的體驗跟包廠一樣。
而且因為是10月份。
所以天氣也不是特別的熱。
那麼整體的體驗就非常的不錯。
其實我是覺得花火這個東西絕對不能再視區看。
體驗會差很多的
就是如果有條件的話。
大家可以來到日本去找郊外的一些。
或者跑出東京大阪這兩個城市。
你去到外面看一些花火。
就比如什麼玉田川。
玉田川就別去了
什麼江戶川
這些其實每一個都有幾十萬人去看。
而且體驗非常不好。
對
反而像前天我們去的次城的那個。
然後去年我們去的富士山的那個。
以及我們即將在今天下午。
我們要去的長江的花火。
其實更多的都是在田間地頭。
在郊區或在山裡頭。
它的視野足夠開闊的場地。
足夠大
那麼這個時候你的體驗是完全不一樣。
對
你可以有一種去參與其中的一個享受的感覺。
雖然大家很熱
但至少沒有像都內的這種。
這麼的擁擠
我可以這麼說嗎
可以
所以其實我們在上這一期節目的時候。
我們人就已經在長江附近了。
對
節目上線的當天
就是長江的花火大會。
長江的這個花火
應該是在日本排名第一的花火大會了。
它的規模也足夠大。
它的場地也足夠的開闊。
但即使這樣
其實在那個場地附近的一些橋。
一些道路也都開始就那個交通管制了。
對
而且它會大面積的堵車。
很難想像這個規模要是放在東京。
變成什麼樣
東京就癱瘓了
是的
當然好在這個花火。
它需要放兩個小時。
對
它的時間也是夠長的。
它其實兩個小時在日本花火大會裡面。
已經算很長的了
一般的都是一個半小時。
甚至有的短的半個小時。
45分鐘的都有
對
所以它的規模也是足夠大。
那麼體驗的話
相對來講應該也是不錯的。
不知道這個會有什麼。
但是我有點擔心
是因為咱們現在這個位置。
它的三尺域那個方向有一個橋。
那個會不會擋
我現在比較擔心
那就今天下午見分曉了。
今天下午
明天下午
就是節目上線的那天下午。
對
那其實下二季的邏輯跟這個花火大會。
又是完全不一樣的。
就是花火大會的話。
我們現在每一年
可能會挑一個比較經典的。
或比較好的一些
去看一看
即使說比較遠
一樣長鋼的話
我們開邀街的話
單程要300多公里。
但是下二季就不是。
下二季我們現在每年也會去。
但是會挑一些比較市井的地方。
比較居民的地方
因為每一個小區
每一個廟
每一個社區
每一個縣
每一個市
它們都有自己的特色。
或者我覺得有時候。
下二季都不是說
我主動去找的
而是在逛街的時候偶遇的。
就我之前去個橫濱的一個下二季。
它就是逛街
突然在一個轉角
然後看到了一個正在舉辦的活動。
人不是特別多
但是大家那種唱歌跳舞的氛圍。
包括旁邊那些小吃什麼的。
我覺得整個這種氛圍就很輕鬆。
而且那天還偶遇了。
非常好看的夕陽
所以我會覺得比去那種最大的。
它效果可能還好一點。
所以這種下二季的話。
其實不用去特別的去尋找。
反而是當你隨機的遇到了一個。
然後去參與其中的那種感覺是。
格外有意思的
對
就我們上週去蓬公家聚會。
然後正好他們家住的是一種老式的團地。
就是團地就是日本的聯租房。
公租房
就得抽選的那種
對
因為東京都內的太人氣了。
就是像國內的小區。
所以他們小區裡面。
週末就辦了這個下二季。
然後中間會搭一個舞台。
然後往四周扯的各種燈籠和彩燈。
周邊是各種攤位
就是這個氛圍其實看起來就很熱鬧。
舞台上就有人在唱歌奏樂。
然後下面四周的人就圍著它。
就跟那個勾火跳舞一樣。
就在那跳舞
對
而且這種社區內的下二季。
其實跟那種公共的下二季不太一樣在哪。
就是像這種社區的下二季。
好多都是街坊鄰里。
他們互相都認識的。
尤其是帶著孩子的。
孩子現在在一塊兒玩。
他們家長很多都是認識的。
那麼一起去參與其中。
甚至有一些居民
還是這個下二季的一個組織者。
或者說是委員會的議員。
他們有一種
作為社區議員內現實的參與感。
但是在這種公共的下二季裡面。
只是說我作為一個觀眾。
作為一個外來人
去看去參加這個下二季。
就是它這個感覺是完全不一樣。
對
而且他們那個下二季一年。
其實就半那麼兩天。
就正好我們去的時候就趕上了。
尤其我覺得特別不一樣的。
就在於他們家那個客廳是團地。
是榻榻米的
然後陽台也很大
所以你可以透過榻榻米的這個客廳。
往陽台望的時候
就可以看到他們樓下的那個下二季的燈光。
你能夠在家裡面就感受到這種。
很愉快的下二季的氛圍。
是
那聲音已經大到我們淡盤小聲點說話。
都是那些地方說啥。
對啊就是非常有日式夏天那種感覺。
所以我覺得
如果當時在陽台上還可以掛一些風靈的話。
就特別像出現在日漫。
或者是日劇裡頭的場景。
對
其實當時你和你那個女生。
不是在陽台看他們去表演嗎。
我和男生其實在看你們的時候。
就有點像看那個日劇裡面。
就是你們的背景是下二季。
然後你們在陽台上在那邊看的。
在那邊說話什麼的。
就我們倆應該還在拿個酒。
對我剛想說
就更好了
再拿一個夏日版的火爐幼蟻的那種感覺。
就非常的有氛圍感。
就非常的夏天
所以這個其實就是我們在日本久了以後。
這種日本的傳統的過夏天的方式。
之於到我們身上的一些變化。
那除此以外呢？
我們現在可能過夏天的方式。
更多的就是
跟家呆著
逛商場
哪有空調去哪
那還是跟家呆著吧？
聽蟬鳴
對
然後我們還會融合很多。
我們在國內的習慣。
就比如說我們現在也會做涼麵。
雖然不是經常
但是我們也會買西瓜回來挖著吃。
雖然沒有實現西瓜自由。
但是我們會把國內的。
對於夏天的記憶當成。
我們在日本過夏天的一種儀式感。
所以就變成了一種算是文化融合嗎。
我也不知道這樣說恰不恰當。
就是融合了日本和國內過夏天的習慣。
然後開發出了一套屬於。
我們自己的一套過夏天的方式。
還有一個就是吃羊肉串。
吃羊肉串
你不覺得這個很夏天嗎。
就是炒羊肉串喝啤酒。
很夏天
對不對
在國內的話
大家一會兒去外面就能吃了。
但是現在在日本的話。
我們只能是自己的家裡烤。
但是非常的夏天對不對。
是的
所以大家聽到這也可以在評論區裡面。
跟我們分享出來
你們有什麼樣獨特的。
關於夏天的記憶
以及你們當地特有的過夏天的方式。
那麼同樣的也可以在聽我的訊。
然後進去跟大家討論一下。
在夏天有什麼樣的好吃的。
好玩的以及過夏天的方式。
那麼以上就是本期節目的。
全部也能到這裏放來張口。
我是老飯
我是雪莉
我們下期再見
拜拜